okay now part c let's chalk this
and one again down to read the question
carefully
part c says sketch the curve defined by
the modulus for z minus two equals two
we're pretty fine with this um i
did find it mildly disappointing there
were so many people who found a circle
really hard to draw but some of you i
just barely gave it to you because um
you know it was it was circular like and
i saw scale and like kind of thing but
if there was not consistent scale on
your circle it doesn't look like a
circle
i can't pay that right but then on the
same night diagram
there were three things being looked for
when you've got a three mark question
number one
there's a region sketch the region
defined by these
inequalities now the key thing that uh
pretty much everyone missed
was this word in here it says or
so or means the union between two
sections if you think back
um you know if you've got a number and i
say you know x is less than negative
three
or x is greater than 2 if you satisfy
either one of these inequalities that's
fine so i could put this on the number
line like so
let's put 0 1 2 3 1
2. so if i call this 2 and negative 3
which part of this do i shade it's going
to be this and to the left
this and to the right so in other words
you include both of them right
therefore you've got this inequality
here which is inside the circle
and then you've got this inequality here
which is the entire plane
that has an argument between pi and four
and pi
as measured from this point here the
reference point being two
and so that's why you know several of
you got the
got this boundary correct but then you
said well i'm just going to include this
part here
because you forgot that this part was
also included
so that region was what i was looking
for but then secondly
the question itself it states labeling
all boundary points and equations and
there was barely anyone
who did either of those things this you
know you've sort of done this circle
here i put the cartesian equations
because i think that's clearer but
even if you put the complex equations
you know the absolute value of
uh all the modulus for z minus 2 equals
2.
that was kind of borderline okay because
i didn't state that you needed the
cartesian equation however it was a big
no-no if you went to that boundary
and you labeled that with an inequality
because an inequality is not a re it's
not a boundary it's a region it's the
thing that you shaded
but this question clearly states give me
the boundary
points and boundary equations so that's
why you really
uh desperately needed to have an equal
sign there
and also i don't know if there was
anyone who labeled this key boundary
point over here a lot of people put the
four in
you put the zero the origin in that was
great but this is clearly a junction
where things changed
and so you can see down here this is me
working out the solution
to find that point of intersection so
when the question says
find the boundary points maybe spend
some time finding the boundary points
okay that was
part c and then the final part
part d alright this is quite a tough one
that's why it was the last question on
the paper
consider the complex number z equals cos
theta plus i
sine theta now i'm going to highlight
that because
there is immediately later on in the
question something which refers to that
cos theta plus i sine theta this is not
just any complex number this is
a specific family of complex numbers
because when we write complex numbers in
polar form
we would normally write them with an r
at the front right and this indicates
the modulus
now because you don't have an r stated
here that means r that's implied that r
is equal to
one so therefore you have these complex
numbers zed they sit
on the unit circle which you can see
just down here in part two
it says you're going to need to use that
fact that this lies on the unit circle
um to be able to prove these results so
therefore
let's now dive into our result okay part
one says
using demarcus theorem show that z over
n plus
one over z over z to the n is purely
real for any integer value because um
demolition only applies for integers so
there's a couple ways to go about this
you could use negative indices which was
fine because uh democracy theorem holds
for negative indices
so here is me whoopsie daisy here's me
quoting
um demarcus theorem just for z to the n
and then here is me quoting demarco's
theorem for
um z to the negative n so you can see
that negative n
there happening twice and then what i
can say is okay well let's look at this
carefully right
cos of negative n theta that's the same
as cos n theta and crucially
i gave a reason for it that's because
cos x is an even
function and i make the same argument
here that you've got this i
sine minus n theta which is the same as
minus
sine and theta but not because i say so
it's because sine x is an odd
function now again coming back to the
question this is
two marks and it says show that show
that we're not interested in the answer
so much as we're interested in the
reasons why the answer is true
and so you've really got to provide
these reasons in here and a lot of
people miss that
so you can see once you've set that all
up you get this cancellation happening
right
so there's the cos n theta um and it's
going to collect like terms with the
other cosine theta
um and here's the minus sine n theta
which is going to cancel
with this positive i sine and theta so
you ended up at this result down here
which you definitely needed
for part two speaking of part two it
says
the polynomial p to the z uh p of z
rather equals and then they give you
this uh this long
awkward thing in here it has four
complex roots which all lie on the unit
circle
pause when you've got a polynomial and
it has complex roots
that has four complex roots that means
we're saying when is this equation equal
to zero that's how you find roots right
so that's why oh i've skipped over
something i'll come back to this in a
second
that's why you can see my first line
here is equal to this whole polynomial
and i've let it equal to zero
okay so then what i've done is i've
noticed there's a symmetry to the
coefficients of this and it means that i
can use this result
from part one which is to say
when you've got z to the n plus set to
the negative n these combine and just
give you this real result so
you can see here if i can manufacture
this by dividing through by z squared
you get a z squared here
and a z to the negative 2 this you can
see i've combined
these two here i've underlined them and
it gives you
this term out the front you can do the
same with the z and the z to negative 1
or should i say the 3z and the 3z to the
negative 1.
and then essentially from this line here
i go into the next line by using
part 1. there's that 2 cos n theta
except here ends
2 and here n is 1. once you've expanded
this all out you get
um this result not expand out i should
there you should divide by two
because all these are even two two
sixteen divided by two gives you eight
okay now i got ahead of myself there was
another way to prove uh part one you
didn't have to do it this way
you could have just used like z to the
power of n
plus 1 over z to the power of n and not
done the negative indices even though
they're a bit quicker
so you can see here this is 1 over z to
the n
to deal with that of course you've got
to realize the denominator which is why
i've
named this method that you can see up on
the top here you've got that
complex conjugate on the denominator
you're getting cos
squared plus sine squared so you're
using the pythagorean identity that's
the light force so
you get this result it's over one you
get essentially the same thing that i
got
on this line except i've got it all
divided by one so
there's my cos n theta there
which collects with this term and then
my s i sine n thetas they are going to
cancel so you end up on the same thing
okay we saw part two
and then here comes the final part it
says hence or otherwise show that the
solutions of
p of z equals 0 are 5 plus minus 12i
on 13 negative 1 plus minus root 3i on
2. how do we do that when you have a
look at my solution here you can see
what i've done from the immediately
previous line in part 2
to the first line of part 3 is i've just
used the double angle formula
for cosine right i've just expanded here
so you can see that when i've done that
you get this term here expanding out
into this and then once you've collected
like terms you can see that minus 13
and that eight that gives you this minus
five um you then have a quadratic in cos
uh quadratic and cos theta i should say
which you can solve just like any other
quadratic
so you can see i've i've i've looked at
this i've got 26 and
negative fives they're negative 130 that
product there what's the pair of numbers
that works for that
it's 13 and negative 10. so therefore
you can see me breaking apart doing this
pairwise factorization
leads you here gives you these two
solutions now you already knew that
those were going to be the solutions
because the question
itself told you what the parts were but
then you need to do a little bit of work
to show where the
sign comes from right so better answers
put their
their cos diagrams onto an argan diagram
so you can see here
my triangles are going off to the left
here the left of the imaginary axis
because cos theta equals negative a half
that's the direction it's going in
around the unit circle
so therefore you can work out what your
plus
or minus of the sine theta is because
you've got conjugate solutions here
and then a plus or minus of the sine
solutions here plus minus root 3 on 2
and that gives you the answer that was
required
so this was a challenging test it really
distinguished between students who
understood their concepts understood
them well
and also as you've seen all the way
through this topic you know if you think
back to the first time for instance we
introduced to you
complex numbers in exponential form
rectangular form and polar form and we
said to you hey we're showing you
all these different forms because
different forms are suited to different
types of problems
and that's kind of a metaphor for this
entire topic and indeed all of maths
there are many different methods and
choosing the most effective one makes
everything kind of
line up and your solutions come out
quickly rather than for a long time so
if you felt like you ran out of time
what i would encourage you to do is have
a look at the methods that you
chose compare them to these written
solutions and think about where were the
places that cost you time because the
method that you chose
wasn't the best one or the most most
efficient one so i hope you learned
something out of this paper